journalism is under attack
like never before no muslim creature gas
fire you have to have the fact
beautiful but tragic because people are
doubting everything
you're the only way of telling their
story how would you describe this
outbreak something like an apocalypse
you're going to be
really tired you're going to be really
scared it's too dangerous
anyone who says they're not scared is
life anything can happen
did you get here i sometimes wonder how
have we managed to get out of this be
killed
we do genuinely believe in what we do
he's clearly martial press
to show the truth wow this is absolutely
unbelievable to uncover
an injustice this is the result of
ethnic cleansing i don't think any
journalist wants anything more than that
i'm alex crawford i'm stuart ramsey and
this is hot spots
coming up on hot spots five for brazil
i'm in brazil witnessing the devastating
impact
of covet 19. they simply refuse to
accept
anything needs to be changed at all
welcome to america my team are in texas
where the virus is causing
death and division word number one is a
topic virus number two is stupidity
i couldn't believe exactly what she was
saying you better believe i'm angry
i'm sick of this [ __ ]
i remember thinking at the time this is
just covered nightmare
every single human being is affected by
this
the rain was like nothing i've ever
experienced before
large number of people will die and are
[Music]
dying
had started obviously in the far east we
met it when it reached italy
and knowing the makeup of
the big cities in latin america it
seemed inevitable it was likely to go
to latin america
we talked about brazil we knew that the
numbers were climbing
very very fast there and we knew that we
needed to get in
we knew that we might see not just
overwhelmed health care system but
overwhelmed population
covert 19 had been burning through
brazil
at a tremendous rate and everyone was
getting infected
because the president refused to shut
down the economy bolsonaro
is a populist president who came to
power
promising to support law and order thank
you very much everyone he was very very
quickly labelled the trump of the
tropics because of his
alternative personality we have
many views that are similar anyway she
looks identical they look right
so we thought we needed to go to
brasilia which is where the seat of the
government is
and try and talk to his supporters and
get their view
brasilia is the capital it's a quite
beautiful city
it is also the stronghold of president
bolsonaro
and his cohorts of supporters who have
traveled from all over the country
to come to some of the anti-lock down
rallies that he holds every sunday
i remember arriving in the car looking
down the street and going hold on a
second
this street is round
cars
people dancing
[Music]
backs of trucks with people on
double-decker buses
we saw some cowboys on horses doing what
looked like a sort of right-wing
salute
[Music]
this is remarkable really brazil is
having
tens of thousands of new cases of covert
infections
every
refuse to accept anything needs to be
locked down everything needs to be
changed at all
fighting for brazil
there was a certain amount of
trepidation because we did expect the
supporters to be very very
hostile there have been lots of reports
of media being beaten up
but actually we found really really nice
people
we're here to support our president
because our president he's really tough
really strong they're quite an
interesting
lot they're quite like trump's
supporters die hard trump supporters so
the president can do no wrong
he's trying to expose the truth about
kovite 19.
i think one of the important things that
i do and which
i know my team do we don't judge anyone
this is more danger for you
okay you need oxygen and when
you take out you can have big problem
after if they're going to say that i'm
actually poisoning myself because i've
got a mask on
then i'm going to let them say that i
don't have an argument with about it if
it's shown in a tv program it's up for
everyone to make a decision
everybody knows what's going on you know
but people cannot just
uh rely on mainstream media and it's
always oh the mainstream media
everything you say is a lie
and you can't trust anything but this is
how this fake news apparatus works
the first sign that bolsonaro was on his
way
was he started streaming his helicopter
journey on facebook
from the inside of the chopper i see the
helicopter
fly over and i bashed my camera and i
didn't get the shot
but then that didn't matter in the end
because he did this
again and again and again
it circled around the crowd a few times
and people going wild and cheering
as if the more they cheered the more he
showed off
it's completely bizarre
so he did that whole parade and then his
chopper landed
there he is now
as we got nearer to the front it got
busier and busier
the areas where people are sort of
leading over to touch his hands
that was where you know you have the
most intense thing and i remember
thinking at the time
this is just covered nightmare here
it's hot people are sweating it's
streaming off everyone
now entire trip in brazil that protest
was the one that worried me
the most about contamination and
infection
we were all given training in how to
mitigate the risks
of covid and prior to that i think i was
a lot more afraid of it
than it was after i felt i knew that if
we put the right protocols in place we
could protect ourselves
from contracting the virus the
remarkable thing about coronavirus has
been its spread
how it came from the far east spread
west came to
to north america and south america very
similar times and then kept spreading
then we started getting reports of
actually it going
up the amazon and the real fear is for
the indigenous people who
live up there we talked a lot about
going
to see an indigenous community
specifically who were isolating
we made the decision as a team that
we would be putting them too much at
risk
although we all knew we were healthy and
well the other thing with coronavirus is
you just don't know do you
we compromised on going to a riverside
community their antibodies are much
higher
they are used to more common illnesses
and the place we went to we knew
coronavirus was already spreading
okay i found ponchos couldn't get black
but
green cool and then yellow better than
yellow
okay i'll pop them in the um sometimes
my team thinks i'm mad we'll be talking
about something and i'll just suddenly
say oh i need
to do that and they're like i'm like no
and that was ponchos
we were having a random conversation
about something i said we need to find a
shop
why i need to buy ponchos why because i
think it's going to rain really hard and
we're going to be
stuck on a boat and we're going to be
absolutely soaked
and that's not going to be great it's
like yeah actually that's true
what do you make of the boat apparently
it's main selling point it's fast
we started out on our boat journey and
it was absolutely beautiful
there was blue skies sun was shining
the river was really really calm it was
like a mirror
you could see the sky in the river was
absolutely beautiful
in the distance you can see sheets of
rain you can see it coming
we were going quite fast then you know
suddenly we hit it
the rain was like nothing i've ever
experienced before
we're talking about amazon rainforest
rain it is
serious rain really hard in
all directions and relentless
i'm getting lashed by a rainstorm it's
very surprising we are in a rainforest
so it took us probably a good five hours
to get there which is
in this grand scheme of things is
nothing five hours into the amazon
you've only just made a tiny dent into
it
i mean you could go for days down the
river
we joined this medical ship that sails
deep into the forest and we arranged to
meet them
in a village that they were working in
where they were
testing for covid separating those who
they thought had the symptoms to carry
out tests
and basically to track and trace where
they live which village they're in
how many members of their family so they
can actually have a guess of just
a how much it was spreading and b who's
ill and how do we
make sure that they gain proper
assistance
these river communities do have meetings
with the outside world on a fairly
regular basis which is why
covet has spread here the problem is
though in
even more remote areas even the common
cold
can kill a whole community so covet 19
will just decimate them
the doctors are trying to stop it the
point is
the lockdowns are easing and people are
traveling again and the more travel
the more this disease is spreading the
doctors are really worried
that a second wave of this infection
coming from the cities is going to
continue to spread
into some of the most remote
parts of the world
[Music]
one thing i realized on this trip was
that i felt
much further for my family than i'd ever
felt before
every single human being is affected by
this
that's the magnitude of this story so i
was leaving
my family at home in the midst of a
pandemic that was happening there too
so it made me feel a very very long way
from her
manaus is in the north west section of
brazil
right in the amazon rainforest it had
been ravaged by
the virus one thing that we noticed
compared to other places we had been
around the world was actually that the
healthcare system
in brazil wasn't that overwhelmed and
the reason for that was because a lot of
people were dying at home
when we got to manaus dominique had set
up a shoot
with a company called sos funerals
it's a company that provides funerals
for people that can't afford to pay for
a funeral themselves
bodies have to be recovered bodies have
to be given a
respectful burial so by definition it's
for the poorest people and they go to
the
if you like the pauper's graves
we traveled with them around as they
were picking up
bodies we were with them for a day or so
it really basically is raining all the
time in the rainy season you just have
breaks in it
i steer away from birds like biblical
but actually it was pretty remarkable
absolutely lashing
[Music]
one of the calls that we got
was to a house in a fairly poor
neighborhood and as we arrived in that
neighborhood we could already see all
the people
stood in the street and they were all
looking on because one of their
neighbours had died
like many communities the family didn't
believe that this man had died from
covert 19.
all the telltale signs were there the
street had been a bit of a hot spot for
the virus
but without any testing of course
there's no real way that you can
actually
know we don't know with a lot of these
things as to whether actually the person
has died from curvid or not
in the current climate of course
everyone has to assume they are
people here are obviously extremely
upset but
uh this has been happening non-stop and
it's going to continue i'm sure
you have to be very sensitive about how
you go about
filming a body
to not show too much so that you get an
image that
yes it's a dead body but it's not so
intrusive as to offend
you know everybody has dignity even in
death
you also have to be wary of families of
course you know
people that are mourning lost ones so
there'll be a lot of emotions
involved for the people that are left
behind
we witnessed a lot of grief that day
i think it is always difficult if you
don't have any empathy with the people
you can't possibly do the story justice
you've got to take
every death as an individual and it
doesn't matter if it's a soldier
somewhere
a child a old person you have to give
them equal respect for what it is it
means to their immediate family members
we followed the funeral van to the main
cemetery in manaus
it was very quiet it was very somber
as they took the coffins to the graves
on a truck
there was this procession of families
that were carrying their crosses and
things and
it was just it was just very sad
it was a mass burial they were mass
graves
it was one big hole and each coffin was
going into that one big hole
the very sad thing about this virus is
that everyone dies alone
what people also don't realize that
people can't mourn together
as well the funerals are strictly
controlled on the numbers of people that
can come in
so normally everyone in the family would
come but now they're down to three
what really touched us and i didn't
really believe my eyes when i first saw
it but they didn't just
dump the muddy
the driver pushed it gently over you
could actually see him
just ease the mud into the grave and i
think that was to show respect to the
family show respect that it was a person
it wasn't just another victim so that
was very very
touching the workers there tried to take
the sting out of it
by then individually marking the graves
after the earth had been filled
it could have been so much worse i mean
it really could have just been
dropped into the grave and covered in
mud it was a remarkable
experience
you know you'll never get over going to
the amazon i mean there's just no two
ways around it
it's just always amazing
what i will take away though is
the people we met just how scared they
are for their families
everyone we spoke to was saying it's
terrible
[Applause]
the president's view has always been
that
poverty and hunger and economic downfall
would
affect his population more than the
virus but
that argument is extremely difficult to
make
to the tens of thousands now who have
died
and their families
perhaps the brazilian government also
understood that there wasn't much it
could do
it doesn't have the infrastructure or
the wealth necessarily
so the virus has run a mock in brazil
and is showing no signs of slowing down
i think the kovid has just changed the
world
it's changed every country i think
the strength of a nation is going to be
apparent from how they deal with the
aftermath
the thing is we're nowhere near any
aftermath yet
this will go on for a long time and that
will
affect countries like brazil for
potentially generations
up next i'm killing myself for something
that i believe was preventable
but seeing someone who's obviously
suffering
i just didn't want to watch it social
distancing
is false
i fancied meeting cowboys
kobit 19 is not going away
we're fighting towards war number one is
a
copy virus port number two is stupidity
coronavirus has killed
not one person by itself worldwide
that's a fact
that is not a fight i got a news flash
part of life
is death
the virus they're working hard looks
like by april you know in theory when it
gets a little warmer it
miraculously goes away the president of
america had been
basically at the forefront of what
appeared to be
disinformation about this deadly virus
the cdc is advising the use of
non-medical
cloth phase covering he sort of turned
it into a macho
thing i don't think i'm going to be
doing it well america was
suffering from not only the infection
rate but had very high death rates
i felt it was a pandemic long before it
was called a pandemic
generators a lot of noise about whether
the virus was actually
real or not the democrats are
politicizing the coronavirus
this is a matter of life and death and
this is their new hoax
paul the virus a hoax he didn't really
appear to want to take control or blame
governors will be empowered to tailor an
approach
that meets the diverse circumstances of
their
own states that set the train of
how it was dealt with or not dealt with
we're not going to let the cure be worse
than the problem i guess i'm doing okay
because
to the best of my knowledge i'm the
president of the united states texas was
very very keen to lift the lock down
as quickly as possible
here we go
today we're going to get out and meet
people that are going to take us places
tell our stories emily upton
was our producer she's based in america
half american so she had an awful lot of
experience about how the americans were
coping with it
in new york people were very uh
cooperative and unified in their view
that
everyone does their bit to help each
other wear your mask
is that everything
so it was going to be interesting to see
how
the general public was responding to the
crisis in houston
what's that long line for
it's gone all the way around the corner
as well we had been reading a lot about
the pain that families were feeling not
just
as a result of coronavirus hitting their
families
health but economically it went
on round the block and around the block
and round the block
and then when we found the start of it
we realized there were all these people
lining up to get food parcels
how many more people have you got coming
through here as a result of
covert 19. easily we've doubled our
number
you know what you see in people's faces
more than anything
shock shock they can't believe that this
is the situation that they're in
there was a long long long long queue
and it went on for the bulk of the day
it's got to run into thousands i would
say
how do you feel about having to come to
a food bank
words just can't really explain it
though you know because it's something
that you know all your life
you've been used to depending on
yourself and now you have to depend
pretty much on someone else to help
feed you and your family
while they were there they could also
get tested for free
what's made you come here uh my coworker
tested positive
for coronavirus since we worked together
i thought i'd get tested
america was heading towards
not only record global figures
of coronavirus infections and deaths but
also
record global figures of
an economic collapse
i mean they were facing the worst
possible economic crisis
since the great depression the way
people were feeling in houston
people are speaking their mind and
getting out on the streets
the issue of coronavirus and the
response to that
was also contentious for many
it wasn't too hard to find
people who were known as anti-maskers
so we turned up outside um houston city
hall
they told us there's gonna be hundreds i
mean maybe thousands of people
actually only about a dozen
were there i'm against it because i have
a little bit more faith in my body and
how it works
the molecules of the virus is so small
it's still penetrating to your
mask i think people will need to don't
think anyone said it is foolproof
they're saying that it cuts it down you
couldn't you couldn't shift them from
that view
there is no criteria to subjugate
citizens constitutional rights under
a hoax that we know this coronavirus is
because why do you think it's a hoax
well bottom line it was a manufactured
chinese virus that was designed to
incapacitate our military forces
someone who's so ideologically
driven with one point of view is really
hard to dislodge
the words that come out of my mouth come
from my head and from my heart and the
passion that i have they don't come out
of my ass like all of these politicians
i got a news flash
part of life is death and only the
strong survive
each and every single day it's called
the circle of life
when you pass out don't ask me for help
because i'm not going to help you
why are you angry if i wear them because
you're wearing a mask out of stupidity
and you're further pushing the agenda
and the agenda is the deep state
which wants to control all of us and
have us living in fear and thinking that
you're contaminated this is a tactic
used by the c i a to torture people
social distancing is false if anything
it would be
physical distancing and what the
government the deep state is doing and
our stupid governor abbott is telling
people
is that we must social distance and wear
a mask i've got an immune system for
that and i follow top
doctors that know what they're talking
about and aren't speaking through their
ass
and they do not absolutely believe this
it is
false narrative and when you wear a mask
which you can certainly do
you are further pushing the agenda that
is condemning all of us
and keeps us living in a state of terror
where i can't even go to the bank to
deposit money
because i'm contaminated i'm contagious
and i have to sit out in my car and wait
for an hour
just to deposit money because there's a
line an hour long
that's why i mean what would you should
do
i i think i just sort of thought i
better just take it
alex handled it really well because she
she let the lady
say what she had to say and she
interjected
you know when she needed to to correct
facts but all of a sudden
a ringing thing fabricated virus comes
along and you're gonna plop dead
are you serious are you thinking ma'am
with all due respect are you using your
critical thinking
or just following the mainstream media
coronavirus has killed not one person by
itself
worldwide that's a fact that that is not
a fact so
[ __ ] it is so so okay you showed me
one person that's died just from corona
show me
we we've seen people dying i guarantee
you if you did a true autopsy of that
person
you would have found that they had
underlying conditions already in their
bodies
that allowed their bodies to stop
functioning they already had as we said
one foot in the grave
i mean i come away from almost every
interview thinking i should have asked
that i should have asked that i should
have pointed that out
don't look at me like i don't know what
i'm talking about i'm a very intelligent
woman
[Music]
i was conscious of driving in america
emily did most of the driving but it's
then difficult to map read and
you know i'm in the front with the
camera ready to film stuff occasionally
alex is a terrible driver let me i'll
just say this now
yeah i kind of wanted to do a lot of the
driving
is all i say on that
and that my friend just have to drive a
car
terribly as well
oh no there's very strict
privacy laws in hospitals about people's
identities
so getting access to hospitals in
america is
quite a tough call
hospitals are run like businesses here
and
a business does not want to show the
world how it's struggling
generally the only thing that you will
leave is your underwear please
they've only they haven't got petite so
i've gone for just extra small
look at me you look like a doctor
the pee pee in this hospital was on
another level
thank you i mean we had double
everything
whereas initially we were 46 beds total
now on we're 58 beds all together on
this side
and we're opening another 30 beds uh
right now
first thing that we're going to do is
we're going to have a second layer
another layer
you will have to wear two sets of gloves
thank you
because everyone had all this double
this double that double headgear double
gloves
you couldn't tell anyone from anyone we
all looked like strange astronauts
oh oh lordy that that's gonna frighten
your patience not put them in your
started
oh not at all oh my god it's frightening
you could have smiled what am i looking
like really terrified
[Music]
was an incredible character he was a
news team's dream
he loved the attention loved the camera
that enthusiasm was utterly
infectious let's go a lot of people say
if i go to a hospital i'm going to
either catch corona
or i'm going to die welcome to america
how do you want me to look
do you think that the lockdown was
lifted too
early in texas way too early way too
early
should have never been lifted never
when you're staying at home and you're
isolated
there's better management but
our governor went along with the
president
so we got screwed
explain what's happening doctor we're
trying to
kind of liberate or empty some of the
extra air that he has on the stomach he
has a very distended belly
it's gonna be it's a very uncomfortable
very important
i just didn't want to watch
[Music]
it's seeing someone who's obviously
suffering that's
that's quite difficult to watch that
looks so uncomfortable
you are breathing through your mouth a
lot of them are
so some of that air is gonna go into
your stomach and eventually as the
stomach gets bigger
it pushes against your lungs and you
cannot breathe so it's kind of a vicious
circle
so we have to remove some of the air
his stomach seems to have gone down
already so it's had an immediate effect
it is those scenes are difficult to
watch
they're very difficult to film it's
always a bit of a
argument about whether it should be
broadcast or not
i personally think they should be
broadcast because
if you think a deadly virus is
all cushy and clean and
not nasty then you you've got the very
wrong impression
it kills you coronavirus kills you
we're fighting two two wars word number
one is a copy virus
port number two is stupidity because
there are some people out there that
just
really i don't know how they are still
alive
how worried are you about the fourth of
july weekend
avoid mass gatherings don't go to
parties don't go to the beach
because i don't have enough beds for you
let's just put it that way okay
you will die i mean it's simple as that
there is no
more mr nice guy if you go out this
fourth of july your mass gathering
you have the potential of dying yourself
or killing somebody else
americans take their holidays very
[Applause]
[Music]
seriously
[Music]
alex won't thank me for saying this she
was absolutely
100 not going to leave america without
filming a rodeo
i fancied meeting cowboys
what's quintessentially texan what's
quintessentially american
[Music]
interesting the loudspeaker announcement
that fairly regular
interviews telling people you know thank
you for wearing your mask today
but you look around and hardly anyone's
wearing masks
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you feel that the coronavirus has
affected celebrations
uh it kind of sucks like they've been
shutting a lot of us down but uh
we find stuff to go to and make do this
how we make our living so we gotta make
[Music]
it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
vox pop i think the latins of oxford's
populist the vox pop is hugely important
to
telling any story a very unscientific
sample of people's opinions i'm not
scared of the corona
man if i get it i get it it's no big
either
we're not worried i ain't worried about
it the only thing i'm worried about is
my
when the good bullet calls me home i'm
going home regardless if it's
a virus or what it is
[Applause]
[Music]
we randomly spoke to people
in the rodeo and they all
unconnected said very similar things i
think it's a bunch of stuff made up
i don't i don't agree with it at all i
don't always agree with it
but you know i work outside and i'm in
the outside
environment here in texas so it's hot
you know it's hard to wear the mask
continually
they weren't going to be told what to do
because it's against their
constitutional rights
they shouldn't be able to dictate what i
wear i pay my taxes
i live free i want to be free they
really saw it as a
as a battle for liberty somehow
[Applause]
i don't know if everyone there fully
appreciate the dangers in you know
hospitals becoming overwhelmed
sure it's on the news but a lot of
people choose to ignore that
this is nbc nightly news with lester
hull we are heading into a july 4th
holiday weekend
like we have never seen before 37 of the
50 states have case numbers that are
rising we are heading into what the
health experts fear could be an
especially dangerous weekend
for the spread of the coronavirus cope
at 19
is not going away in fact
it's getting worse
[Applause]
can you come hello hey guys
we went back to the hospital because
he'd forecast this armageddon
patient coming through so everyone's
been told to put her on their marks the
hospital is much more full on our second
visit
welcome to the intensive care unit at
united memorial medical center
where the local time is 8 39 pm
and dr veron is still here they were
losing people
and no doctor likes to lose anybody
are you worried about this well
again this was foreseeable i'm upset
i'm truly upset that we're having to go
through this and you know
i'm killing myself for something that i
believe
to some extent was preventable
these doctors and nurses have been going
for
days on end hours on end with no real
sleep
and they were still stepping up to the
plate
exhausted but doing their jobs and
really trying to help people what would
you say
to people who don't believe that it's as
serious
as it is i would say to them
as an example sitting here in this bed
have gone through it
that it is serious it's not a hoax
it's like a a green slime
floating in the air and it could drop on
anyone
at any time
how many did you lose this week
um about five well
that must be quite upsetting yeah
i think it's quite emotional working
here it takes quite a toll on these
these guys who are so young is this is
this like a diary
yeah even here
why did you write it on your tunic
because we cannot take paper out
so i'm very happy with this because you
can actually see him
getting better oh yeah that must make
you feel good
it actually gets me more energy to keep
on doing what i'm doing
it's like i told her it's one it's what
we're good at
and it it justifies our existence in
this world which is nice
it's really nice i mean it makes you
feel so good
oh boy
coronavirus is placing restrictions on
everything
and it's difficult to to cope with that
and the working environment's just made
so much harder as a result
what really sticks on my mind about that
trip is the lady shouting at us in the
street about wearing masks
with all due respect are you using your
critical thinking
or just following the mainstream media i
genuinely found listening to the
anti-masters
completely revelatory because i'd never
met
anyone who really completely
utterly believed that the whole thing
was a hoax
it's kind of funny but it's also quite
shocking
because you just don't expect that kind
of animosity
when you're doing something to protect
other people anything that happens in
america
will have an impact everywhere else in
the world
how they deal with the pandemic their
approach
to a global deadly disease drips down
through their own country but then
spills over to
the borders to everywhere else
next time on hot spots
oh my god my team's in beirut
to witness a city picking up the pieces
after a deadly explosion
every single building is affected
all broken where we go it is absolutely
full
and i returned to italy to find out what
happened to the people i met
at the very beginning of the coronavirus
pandemic
the worst place with the worst outbreak
is actually recovering
so much better until then you can find
us on twitter
at alex crawford sky and at ramsey sky
see you next time
[Music]
we all need somebody
to lean lean on me